Transcriber: Can Boysan
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Merhaba İstanbul.
Böyle Bon Jovi gibi
başlamak istedim konuşmama.
Genelde, ülkemizde İstanbul'a
gelen şarkıcılar, sanatçılar
konsere başlamadan önce
öğrendikleri tek Türkçe kelime
"merhaba"yı kırık bir Türkçeyle
"Merhaba İstanbul" şeklinde söylerler
ve izleyenlerden bir alkış kıyamet kopar.
Sanki böyle Fûzulî'den
bir beyit okumuşçasına.
Efendim ben Emre Gönlüşen.
Ben spor spikeriyim.
Sanmıyorum ama eğer beni
bilmiyorsanız, tanımıyorsanız
artık günümüzde teknoloji çok gelişti.
Telefonlarınızdan da
her şeye ulaşabilirsiniz,
küçük bir arama yaparsanız.
Gerçi Google'a adımı yazdığınız zaman
hemen karşınıza şöyle sonuçlar çıkıyor:
"Emre Gönlüşen kanser mi?"
"Emre Gönlüşen ne kanseri?"
Durumun böyle olduğunu
büyük kızım Koza'nın annesine gidip
"Anne, babam kanser mi oldu?"
demesiyle öğrendik.
İki kızımızdan da o güne kadar
bunu saklamaya çalışmıştık.
Büyük kızım ilkokul üçüncü sınıfa gidiyor
ve arkadaşlarına beni göstermek istemiş.
Google'a adımı yazmış
ve Google gerisini tamamlayıvermiş.
Durumun çok düşündükleri gibi
olmadığını anlatmaya çalıştık.
Hastanede geçirdiğim süre dışında
genelde evde vakit
geçiriyordum, dinleniyordum
ve kızlarım bir şeylerin
ters gittiğinin farkındaydı.
Zaman zaman gelip soruyorlardı,
"Baba iyi misin, nasılsın?" diye,
ben de onlara çok iyi olduğumu,
hep onların başında, yanlarında kalmaya
devam edeceğimi söylüyordum.
İyileşmenin yanı sıra,
kızlarına verdiği sözü tutan bir babanın
mutluluğunu da yaşıyorum aynı zamanda.
Eğer on gün önce karşınıza çıksaydım
konuşma bu minvalde devam edecekti
ama yaklaşık on gün önce
tekrar hastalandığımı öğrendim.
Doktorumun tabiriyle yeni bir
savaşa başladım yaklaşık on gün önce.
Ama kızlarıma bir kere söz verdim,
onların başında kalmaya,
onlarla birlikte olmaya devam edeceğim.
Bunu anlatmamın bir sebebi var.
Belki birazcık içinizi burkan
hızlı bir giriş yapmış olabilirim
ama dünya kurulduğundan bu yana,
insanlar hep negatif olaylarla,
olumsuz hikâyelerle daha fazla ilgilenmiş,
olumlulara nazaran.
Mesela bir insanın ölüm haberi,
aynı insanın doğum haberinden,
düğün, evlenme haberinden
çok daha büyük ilgi çekmiş.
Bir örnek vermem gerekirse
4 Şubat Dünya Kanser Günü'nde
hasta olduğumu belirttiğim
bir tweet attım.
2.5 milyondan fazla
insan tarafından görüntülendi,
on binlerce beğeni,
binlerce insan sağ olsun bana
geçmiş olsun mesajlarını ilettiler.
Barcelona kulübü benim için
bir geçmiş olsun mesajı yayınladı.
Sayın Spor Bakanı beni telefonla aradı,
geçmiş olsun dileklerini ilettiler.
Çok moral verici ve güzel bir durumdu.
Aynı şekilde iyileştiğimi belirttiğim
bir tweet attığımda
yine insanlar ilgi gösterdi,
geçmiş olsun mesajları,
kutlama mesajları aldım.
Barcelona kulübü beni yine unutmamıştı.
Ama ilgi, alaka ilkinin
arkasında kalmıştı
ve maalesef ben üçüncü kez
bir tweet atmak zorunda kaldım,
hastalığın geri geldiğiyle,
nüksettiğiyle ilgili.
Sonrasında yaşananları hâlâ,
nasıl anlatayım size,
anlatamıyorum sonrasında yaşananları.
Türkiye'deki bütün spor kulüpleri
bana geçmiş olsun mesajı yayınladı.
Sayın Bakan, Belediye Başkanları,
Federasyon Başkanları,
futbolcular, basketbolcular.
Tabii ki Barcelona kulübü,
sağ olsunlar beni unutmadılar,
kankam oldular artık.
Televizyon kanallarında,
ana haberlerde kendimi izledim,
hastalığım ve bana olan destekle alakalı.
Moralim o kadar çok yükseldi ki
doktorumu aradım, dedim ki
ilaçları kesebiliriz artık ben iyileştim,
bunlar bana yeter de artar bile.
Evet biliyorum.
Negatif durumlar,
üzücü olaylar, stres, sıkıntı
çok çabuk bizi ele geçiriyor.
Hemen vücudumuzu ve bizi üzüyor.
Ama asla ve asla bizi üzmesine
izin vermememiz gerekiyor.
Pozitif düşünce yüzlerce yazılmış
kişisel gelişim kitabından,
çok ama çok daha fazla önemli
ve etkili aslında insan hayatında.
Yapmamız gereken tek şey
bunun birazcık farkına varabilmek.
Aslında bu durumu bize
yine negatif olaylar anlatıyor.
Mesela bir cenaze gördüğünüz zaman
çok üzülürsünüz.
Hayat çok kısa, hiçbir şeyi takmaya
değmez dersiniz.
Ama sonra, ya ben elektrik
faturasını ödemedim,
şimdi ne yapacağım diye düşünüp
sanki bundan daha önemli dünyada
bir sorun yokmuş gibi davranırsınız.
Gerçi faturalar,
bunlar çok küçük problemler.
İnsanların hayatının tam odak
noktasına koyduğu
daha önemli problemler de olabiliyor
ve bunları çözmek
hayatının önceliği oluyor,
belki olmalı da, çözmeliyiz de tabii ki.
Ama bunları çözerken kendimize
ne kadar zarar veriyor,
psikolojimizi nasıl etkiliyor,
bunlar çok önemli.
Şu hayatta sağlıklı olduktan sonra
yapamayacağımız, inanın
hiç ama hiçbir şey yok.
Eğer sağlıklı da değilsek
maalesef benim gibi,
bu defa sağlığınızı tekrar kazanmak için
elinizden gelen her şeyi
yapmanız gerekiyor,
ki pozitif düşünce devam etsin.
Bir Kayseri deplasmanı dönüşüydü,
Kayserispor, Galatasaray maçı anlatmıştım.
Gece geç saatte eve geldim,
karnımda bir ağrı vardı.
Sabah uyandığımda da ağrı ediyordu,
kuzenimi aradım,
Doktor Cem abiye durumu anlattım.
Gel seni bir muayene edeyim dedi,
gittim muayene oldum.
Küçük testler yaptılar.
Problem acaba apandisitimde miydi,
yoksa kum mu döküyordum.
Biraz daha araştırmak gerekti.
Bir tomografi çektiler ve sonucunda
kolon duvarında kalınlaşma tespit ettiler.
Bu pek iyiye işaret değildi.
Biraz daha ayrıntılı
bakılması gerekiyordu.
Baktılar da ve iki gün sonra doktorlar
bana kolon kanseri olduğumu söylediler.
O an hayatım değişti.
O ana kadar aklımdaki tek şey,
acaba hafta sonu hangi seyahate gideceğim,
hangi maçı anlatacağım, maç anlattığım
zaman insanlar beni beğenecek mi,
yoksa sırf takımları gol yedi diye
Twitter'dan küfür mü yiyeceğimdi.
İşe kendimi o kadar kaptırmıştım ki
biraz işin doğasından,
biraz mecburiyetten,
biraz benim işe bakış açımdan
kendimden adeta ödün veriyordum.
Evet biliyorum, şu an karşınızdaysam
ve bu konuşmayı yapıyorsam
bunda elde etmek için çok uğraştığım
televizyon kariyerimin büyük etkisi var.
Biraz da yaşadığım hastalık
ve bu hastalık beni nasıl etkiledi,
nasıl etkilemeye devam etti
ve benim bundan kurtulurken
yaşadıklarımı size anlatmaya çalışıyorum.
Bu konuşma davetini aldığım zaman
yanımda çok sevdiğim
bir arkadaşım Coşkun vardı.
Bana dedi ki, "Bugüne kadar hep
birilerini başkalarına anlattın,
biraz da kendini anlat" dedi.
Bu aslında çok kolay bir şey değil,
birilerine kendimi anlatmak.
Ama elimden geldiğince
bunu yapmaya çalışıyorum.
Ben Adana'nın en eski mahallelerinden
birinde doğdum, büyüdüm.
Çocukluğum, gençliğim, üniversite dahil
tüm eğitim hayatım Adana'da geçti.
Küçük bir çocukken hayaller kurardım,
bilmiyorum herkes küçükken
veya büyükken hayaller kurar mı?
Ben hâlâ yaşıma başıma bakmadan
hayaller kurmaya devam ediyorum.
Yaşım biraz ilerledikçe,
farkındalığım arttıkça
etrafımdaki insanlardan,
mahalledeki ya da okuldaki arkadaşlarımdan
biraz daha farklı olduğumu
hissetmeye başladım.
Bunu da tabii yaradılışımın, kişiliğimin
ve aynı zamanda ailemin özellikle manevi
olarak bana yaptığı katkı çok büyüktü.
Mesela müzik.
Müzik benim için o kadar önemli,
değerli bir olguydu ki
neredeyse tüm oyuncaklarımdan
daha önemliydi, küçücük bir çocukken.
Tabii mahalledeki arkadaşlarımla
saatlerce yaptığımız futbol maçları
ya da oynadığımız envaiçeşit
oyunların yerini belki tutamazdı
ama müzik beni alıp başka
bir dünyaya götürüyordu.
Müzik demişken biraz ayrıntı vermem lazım.
Babamın Beatles, Rolling Stones
plaklarını dinleyerek büyüdüm
ve belki de bu sayede
konuştuğum dil, ana dilim Türkçe
ama müzik ana dilim İngilizce oldu.
O zamanlar tek kelimesini
anlamadığınız bir şarkı
nasıl oluyordu da sizi alıp
başka bir dünyaya götürüyor,
başka yerlerde sizi hayal ettirebiliyordu.
Evet, bu sihirli hatta mucizevi durum
beni içine aldı adeta.
Dedim ki, ben büyüyünce
sahneye çıkmalıyım,
şarkı söylemeliyim, gitar çalmalıyım,
konserler vermeliyim, yaptım da.
Evet bir Bon Jovi gibi olamadım belki
ama bir klasik Rock grubumuz vardı.
Çok eğlenirdik müzik yaparken.
İnsanları da eğlendirirdik,
soyadım Gönlüşen ne de olsa,
buna uymaya çalışıyorum.
Abim de grubumun üyelerinden
bir tanesiydi hâlâ da öyle.
Abimle birlikte gitar çalmayı öğrendik.
Sadece bir gece sürdü, inanın.
Belki inanmayacaksınız bana
ama alt komşumuzdan gitarını ödünç aldık.
Belki sabaha kadar uğraştık
ve o gece bir şarkıyı baştan sona
çalmayı öğrenmiştim.
Bir gecede bir şarkı
çalmayı öğrendim gitarla.
Bakın bunu ben çok yetenekli bir adamım
demek için anlatmıyorum size asla.
Sadece insanın hayatının
içerisinde farkında olmadığı,
içimizde bir yerlere gömülmüş
ama dışarı çıkmayı bekleyen
birçok unsur var
ve bunu herkesin
yapabileceğini düşünüyorum.
Yaradandan aldığımız yaratıcı ilhamıyla.
Tabii şunu söylemiyorum,
herkes çok büyük değer taşıyan besteler,
dünyayı etkileyecek
besteler yapamayabilir
ya da çok güzel bir resim çizemeyebilir,
baktığınızda sanki
canlıymış gibi hissettiğiniz
ya da akımlar yaratamayabilir
dünyayı değiştirecek
ama mutlaka içinizde dışarı
çıkmayı bekleyen bir şeyler var
ve bunları sadece sırf
insanlar sizi beğensin
ya da birilerinin hayatına
dokunmak için değil,
kendiniz için.
Dünyada yaşadığımız
şu kısacık mutlulukları
daha uzatabilmek için yapmak lazım.
Bu yapılabilir mi? Evet yapılabilir.
Nereden mi biliyorum
çünkü ben yaptım.
Bahsettiğim az önce, küçüklük
hayallerimden bir tanesinin
tam ortasında yaşıyorum.
Arkadaşlarımızla mahallede maçlar yaparken
hem oynar, aynı zamanda
maçları anlatırdım.
Hatta o zamanlar çocukken
bilgisayar oyunlarında anlatıcı yoktu,
sadece maç oynardınız.
Ben onları anlatırdım,
içeriden babam bağırırdı,
"Emre yeter artık sus!" diye.
Radyo dinlerken pazar
günleri öğleden sonra
ben de keşke bunu
yapabiliyor olsam derdim
ve bir gün Adana'da bir yerel televizyonda
kendimi maç anlatırken buldum.
Size, anlattığım ilk maçtan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Asla unutamayacağım.
Evet hiçbir insan yaptığı
ilk işi belki unutamaz
ama benimki gerçekten
birazcık daha farklı.
Tribünlerinde yüzlerce
belki bin tane maç izlediğim
Adana 5 Ocak Stadyumu'nda
bu defa anlatıcı konumundaydım,
mikrofonun başındaydım.
İlk maçımdı, elim ayağım böyle,
şimdiki gibi titriyordu.
Dilim damağıma dolaşıyordu,
futbolcuların isimlerini söyleyemiyordum,
hatalar yapıyordum.
Heyecanım beni bir oraya
bir buraya savuruyordu
ama dakikalar ilerledikçe
o heyecanı kontrol etmeye başladım.
Hatta o heyecanımı alıp
izleyicilere yansıtmaya başlamıştım,
tıpkı yapmam gerektiği gibi,
ta ki maçın 81. dakikasına kadar.
Maçta 81. dakika değerli futbol severler,
orta hakem saha kenarına geldi.
Bir emniyet mensubuyla konuşuyor.
Acaba neler söylüyorlar?
Orta noktayı gösterdi ve maçı tatil etti.
İnanılır gibi değil, maç tatil oluyor.
Bomba ihbarı var değerli izleyenler,
Adanaspor, Mardinspor mücadelesinde.
Aynen böyle oldu.
Hayatta anlattığım ilk maçta
bomba ihbarı vardı
ve stadyum boşaltılmaya başlamıştı.
Durumun orada kalmayacağından emindim
çünkü adeta televizyonculuk, spikerlik,
habercilik kanıma işlemişti.
Ben o kadar yeniydim ki meslekte,
akreditasyon kartım, basın kartım yoktu
ve saha içerisinde kalmama da izin yoktu.
Bir yandan telefonla,
o ana kadar rutin bir alt lig
maçı olan mücadele
spor gündeminin tam ortasına oturmuştu
ve o maçla ilgili bilgi almak istiyorsanız
yapmanız gereken tek şey beni dinlemekti.
Bir kez daha söylemek istiyorum,
bu benim ilk maçımdı.
Gerçekten çok heyecanlıydı.
Sonrasında dışarıya çıkmak zorunda kaldım.
Bomba imha ekipleri, köpekler, aramalar,
taramalar, neyse ki bir şey çıkmadı.
Ben telefonla dışarıda yayınıma
devam ediyordum, şirketin telefonuyla.
Diğer telefonumdan da annem beni arıyordu.
Emre, bomba varmış oğlum, çık oradan diye.
Tamam anne biliyorum
deyip kapattım telefonu.
Yayına devam ettim.
İleriye gitmek istiyordum,
bu iş çok hoşuma gitmişti.
Bunun için bir şeyler yapmam lazımdı.
Ulusal basına geçmek istiyordum
ama ne bir tanıdığım vardı ulusal basında,
ne de bir kontağım,
ulaşabileceğim herhangi biri.
Google'dan araştırmalar yaptım,
Ankara'da bir kurs buldum.
Eski TRT spikerlerinin
hocalarının verdiği bir kurs.
O kursa katıldım ama o kursa
katılmak çok kolay değildi.
Çünkü çalışıyordum,
haftanın neredeyse yedi günü.
Aynı zamanda üniversite öğrencisiydim
ve şu an iki kızlarımın annesi olan
sevgili eşim Nilüfer'le birlikte de
bir hayata devam etmeye çalışıyordum.
Ankara'ya gittim geldim,
beş ay sürdü, zorlu bir süreçti.
Kursu güzel bir şekilde tamamladım.
Ama döndüğümde de her şey
öyle güllük gülistanlık değildi.
Yine tanıdığım kimse yoktu,
yine İstanbul'la
bir bağlantım bulunmuyordu.
Bir gün, bu kez ulusal
bir kanalda maç izlerken
televizyonun köşesinde
bir e-mail adresi gördüm.
Baktım ve e-mail atmaya karar verdim.
Merhaba ben Emre Gönlüşen
diye başlayan bir e-mail attım.
Neler yaptığımı anlattım,
neler yapmak istediğimi anlattım.
Üç gün sonra cevap geldi,
büyük bir şans eseri.
Gel Emre, seni görmek istiyoruz dediler.
Atladım uçağa geldim İstanbul'a,
o zamanlar Adana'da yaşıyorum.
Bana bir maç anlatmamı söylediler,
istediler bir özet.
Tam e-mail atarken
izlediğim maçın özetiydi.
Inter, Milan mücadelesi.
Inter 4-3 kazanmıştı, Adriano
duraklamalarda kafa golü atmıştı.
Anlattım, biz seni arayacağız dediler.
Aradan 20-25 gün geçti ve aradılar
ve artık ben ulusal bir kanalda
spor spikeriydim,
maç anlatıyordum, program yapıyordum
ve haber sunuyordum.
Bu konuda biraz şanslıyım,
kariyerim hep ileriye doğru gitti.
Kariyerimde çok üst seviye
yayınlar yaptım,
çok önemli üst seviye maçlar anlattım.
Dünya spor kamuoyuna mal olmuş
insanlarla yayın yapabilme,
tanışabilme şansı buldum.
Ama bunları yaparken
çok büyük zorluklar da çektim.
Eminim herkes hayatında,
iş hayatında, ev hayatında,
özel hayatında, aşk hayatında
zorluklar yaşıyordur.
Ama ben karşılaştığım maddi,
manevi haksızlıklarla
iyi mücadele ettiğimi düşünüyorum.
Ama bu mücadeleyi yaparken de
kendimi çok yıprattığımı fark ettim,
özellikle hasta olduktan sonra.
İşte söylemeye çalıştığım ana fikir bu.
Başına ne gelirse gelsin,
neyle uğraşıyorsanız uğraşın,
özellikle de iş konusunda
asla kendinizi yıpratmayın.
Şöyle bilimsel bir gerçek var,
insanın hayatını etkileyen,
mutluluğunu etkileyen noktalardan
sadece %10'u dış kaynaklı.
%90'ı içimizde,
Cem Yılmaz'ın söylediği gibi.
Gerçekten içimizde.
Bunu bilimsel araştırmalar söylüyor.
O zaman yapmamız gereken şu,
özellikle dış etkense
sizi herhangi bir şeyle etkilemesine
asla ve asla izin vermeyin.
Belki birazcık sinirlenebilirsiniz,
belki biraz durumu
düzeltmeye çalışabilirsiniz.
Ama daha fazlasına asla izin vermeyin.
Ağır bir ameliyat geçirdim.
Uyandığımda yoğun bakımdaydım,
hemşire hanım başımda duruyordu.
"Birazcık su rica edebilir miyim?" dedim.
Bana, "Hayır Emre Bey
size su veremem çünkü yasak" dedi.
Sadece azıcık su istemiştim.
Sonra şırıngaya birazcık su aldı,
geldi dudaklarımı ve ağzımı ıslattı.
O günden beri su içmenin, nefes almanın,
hatta tuvalete rahat rahat gidebilmenin
dünyanın en güzel şeyi
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Şunu demiyorum, yanlış anlamayın.
Sağlığımız yerinde, oley dolaşalım
Polyanna gibi etrafta.
Asla bundan bahsetmiyorum.
Ama sağlığınız yerindeyse dünyada
hallolmayacak hiçbir nokta yok.
Sözlerimi şöyle tamamlamak istiyorum.
Sir Paul McCartney'nin de söylediği gibi,
"Let it be" yani, "boş verin gitsin."